here are three of ten underrated habits
for you to try beat the Sun up folks you
gotta beat the Sun up if you can't beat
up the roll-up of the Sun up you're
gonna get beat up in life if you make
your bet every morning you will have
accomplished the first task of the day
it will give you a small sense of Pride
and it will encourage you to do another
task and another and another and by the
end of the day that one task completed
will have turned into many tasks
completed making your bed will also
reinforce the fact but the little things
in life matter if you can't do the
little things right you'll never be able
to do the big things right I review my
goals every day I review my results
every week I review my results and my
plans every month every quarter and I
take time to think plan do and review
but I keep repeating that process over
and over again